alors un gros défaut que j'ai mais je
pense que je sais pas si ça va la sonde
doit le dire j'ai une grande gueule mais
j'aime bien j'aime bien dire ce que je
pense et je crois que ça c'est aussi une
force ma qualité bas la qualité
j'aime bien les gens un personnage jean
girard indissociable de magny les
hameaux il s'y était installé en 1964
depuis il oeuvrait à travers plusieurs
engagements
il avait des discussions qui étaient
très franche très directe mais
simplement parce que justement il aime
les gens et il voulait que ça évite que
ça avance que que des problèmes
d'injustice soit réglé très vite et là
dessus il lâchait rien mais c'est à
travers deux créations qui laissera le
souvenir le plus fort le téléthon grâce
à sa mobilisation celle de son épouse et
de ses amis magny les hameaux battent
chaque année des records de dons j'aime
beaucoup les enfants
au début quand j'ai fait les premières
fois qu'on avait fait le téléthon
j'avais du mal à être auprès des enfants
handicapés papa qui me faisait peur - de
là au contraire mais c'était j'avais ma
larme
ceux qui portaient jean girard c'était
aussi la mémoire la sienne et celle de
ses amis anciens combattants en 1997 il
crée le comité local de la fnaca jean
girard est appelé en juillet 1958 il
passera 22 mois en algérie le formidable
qui avait un esprit de camaraderie
le matin les gradés ont salué pas on
serre la main
les gamins nous ont posé toute attente
question est ou non leur dis toujours à
chaque fois la peine de vous battez pas
avant la cour de récréation ne vous
bagarrer pas par les disputes
expliquez-vous mais ne fait pas la
guerre un investissement qui mènera à la
création d'un carré de mémoire en 2015
toutes les générations depuis plus de 20
ans ont eu affaire à lui finalement et
ont appris à 1 p de leur citoyenneté
disparu le 15 novembre dernier que jean
girard avait 82 ans
la ville lui avait promis et l'a promis
à ses amis de la fnaca
le travail autour de la mémoire et de la
paix continuera